ein neuer lockdown im landkreis
gütersloh mittlerweile auch im
benachbarten landkreis warendorf
wir haben uns heute in den ganzen tag
umgehört und umgeschaut und zu sehen wie
die menschen jetzt darauf reagieren dass
sie nachdem es jetzt diese lockerung gab
doch wieder zurückkehren müssen
zu den streng corona maßnahmen eine
lange schlange anstehen zum corona test
denn die angst vor dem virus wird in
gütersloh immer größer immer mehr
menschen sind verunsichert
auslöser der fall turniers der lockdown
betrifft inzwischen jeden deshalb darf
sich hier inzwischen auch jeder testen
lassen
auch ohne symptome stehen halt hier weil
wir am wochenende weg wollte in urlaub
und bevor wir vom vermieter abgewiesen
werden
die korona test nachweisen in der
hoffnung natürlich das negative ist und
dass er dann halt kommen und bleiben
dürfen und dann hörte ich dann auch das
ziel wir dieser test zu machen können
und ich habe zwar keine symptome arbeite
ja auch zu der risikogruppe ein abstrich
nach dem nächsten die ärzte im
dauereinsatz
pro stunde können 100 besorgte
gütersloher getestet werden
gearbeitet wird in drei teams der
anderen aber ist inzwischen so groß dass
die ärzte nicht mehr hinterherkommen wir
haben natürlich viel unterstützung von
den kolleginnen und kollegen die diese
testung in ihren praxen machen in der
region hier die nehmen uns jetzt
hoffentlich heute und die nächsten tage
sehr viel davon ab weil die dürfen jetzt
auch die symptom losen testen was sie
bisher nicht durften neben großer
verunsicherung in der bevölkerung
herrscht in gütersloh noch eine andere
emotion frust wut über den zweiten
lockdown dieser fitnessstudio besitzer
zum beispiel muss jetzt schon wieder zu
machen
sauer bin ich ein stück weit darüber
dass die ganz großen die auf das ganz
große geld verdienen nicht so
transparent sind wie es vielleicht die
kleineren sein müssen also ich würde mir
wünschen dass die großen auch
transparent und ehrlich sind und genau
wie es die kleinen auch machen sich an
die abstandsregeln halten an die
hygieneregeln hall und auch dieser kunde
hat man kann es genauso sagen keinen
bock mehr
geht es dann womöglich um eine woche
aber den schränken überhaupt keinen
glauben ich denke mal das wird der
mindestens drei monaten